what do I think Irish famous potatoes
potatoes food in the general at UK
corned beef corned beef and hash
questions sakes have no idea when I read
shamrock shakes at McDonald's basically
anything green Lucky Charms lucky charms
Lucky Charms really guys and all skin
I've been cooking since debate the age
of ten I grew up in Dublin Ireland and
today we're gonna try some Irish treats
[Music]
hopefully we've got potatoes carrots
cabbage good a bit of mustard this is
looking strong traditionally for st.
Patrick's Day we have bacon and cabbage
but when you understand the origins of
what corned beef and cabbage is all
about it is an Irish dish this looks
pretty good let's try something do we
have a knife I've been given a fairly
extreme knife it's tender rice mm-hmm
I'll sort of mustard is out that is some
hot mustard tastes good it's got that
salty here I'm not opposed to a bit of
corned beef and cabbage in my life
nice you cannot go wrong with a place of
fish and chips as an Irish nation we use
a lot of fish and chips but I guess so
dude the people in the UK as well
nice chips on the side tartar sauce
comes in this little plastic thing I
grew up in Hope in Dublin which is a
beautiful little fishing village so I
have high expectations let's check out
how the Americans do fish and chips
mmm not bad apart from the soggy batter
I could live with that for the moment
but the flavor is there it's been well
seasoned and on to the chips or fries as
you curl them in America not bad not
great as an American version goes I'm
not sure it's quite there I think you
need to come to Ireland to try a proper
fish and chips I'm worried about what
this could even be oh dear God I think
Americans just know how to use the color
green is it meant to be this thick where
did you even get green pancakes honking
food coloring into something I'm calling
a tire the irish part of me is still
somewhat skeptical i think it's time to
try some Oh
there's layers lucky charms and what
looks like some sort of green pea chewy
sweet marshmallowy why is it so thick
sure they're big rains in here Wow
that's sugary I have no idea what's in
here it kind of tastes like cereal
milkshake that's green nothing
necessarily traditional Irish you could
throw in a bit of whiskey and I'd be
happy never in my entire life have I had
at my tongue green that is the influence
of America no no less
[Music]
per day so probably the most
stereotypical thing when it comes to
Irish food we've a long long history of
potatoes there's lots of great ways to
cook potatoes this particular dish has
not celebrated any of those there's some
kind of like stringy hairs in it with
little lumps in them I don't think
that's ever part of the dish that that I
ever had I think we have moved on from
just potatoes but actually when it's a
rainy day and I just want serious
comfort it does come back to a nice you
know mashed potato a bit of Irish stew
lovely crispy potatoes on top I love
players don't you lucky charms
so most stereotypical Irish thing you
can possibly buy there's rainbows lots
of gold don't know what that is little
peach or a cherry and there's definite
of those in Ireland this is a bowl of
sunshine right there and whole host of
sugar as well you can't buy them in
Ireland if you ever saw Lucky Charms as
a kid you were super excited you were
drawn in by the sugar and drawn in by
like the neon colors you know what it's
a bowl of sugar this is why it's
appealing and I kind of like the little
marshmallows as much as this is the most
American version of Irish food I'm not
opposed
[Music]
Arland has the most incredible food
scene at the moment really great food
producers amazing restaurants we're a
small nation that has one day a year
that is celebrated by the world
if the Americans decide they want to
paint everything green fill it with
sugar and turn every milkshake in the
land green I am on board once it
celebrates Ireland and spreads the word
of how bloody brilliant we are I'm a
happy man I think I might just go off
into a corner and eat these by myself
happy st. Patrick's Day
[Music]